we begin this morning with the
investigation into a deadly workplace
shooting near Chicago authorities in
Aurora Illinois say 45 year-old Gary
Martin was let go from his job at a
manufacturing warehouse Friday when he
opened fire on his coworkers five
employees at the Henry Pratt facility
were killed one other was wounded police
say Martin also shot at responding
officers wounding five of them they are
expected to recover Martin was shot and
killed by police following an intensive
search of the twenty thousand square
foot facility Adriana Diaz is in Aurora
Adriana what else do we know about the
shooter right now well Dana we've
learned that Gary Martin was a 15 year
employee of the company and while police
don't know what motivated the shooting
they say the violence unfolded on the
day he was being terminated from his job
they don't know if he initially came to
work with his weapon or if he left and
came back with it one call started
flooding in at 1:24 p.m. Friday
reporting gunfire at the Henry Pratt
manufacturing building which makes
industrial parts approximately four
minutes later the officers arrived on
scene and were immediately confronted by
Gary Martin a 45 year old man armed with
a handgun police say it appears Martin
fired at the first responding officers
from a window hitting one officer while
he was still outside the suspects truck
four other policemen inside all within
the first five minutes because it was
about that event so yeah and it was like
in space and then came another shots
after an hour and a half of searching
the 29 thousand square foot facility
officers located Martin who was believed
to be hiding gunfire was exchanged again
at that time and that's when the that's
when we we shot the shooter Jake Simmons
mother was inside during the incident
she was scared you know at the moment
she said that there are some shots so
they are kind of took cover five of her
co-workers were found dead in the
building
hate that we have to use the term
classic workplace shooting and that
pains me to do so investigators executed
a search warrant at the gunman's home
but nothing material was found
Jacqueline white was Martin's neighbor
he would keep his his stuff to himself I
mean he didn't really have that much
visitors he lives by himself
now Martin does have a criminal record
in 1995 he was arrested and charged for
aggravated assault in Mississippi
Michelle tragic Adriana thank you